[Music]
[Music]
what is up everybody so good to see you
today's it's a Thursday I believe and
you know what it's been a little while
since I've been on livestream so we're a
little rusty I'm gonna have to shake off
the rust here but we have a jam-packed
episode with our kind of most too
prolific logo therapists on the show
today of course we're talking about
marked and Everton and we're doing a
thing again called the logo therapy
where we take two designers who take two
logos and we're gonna talk about them
today so it's two by two mark did you
yawn today today okay you guys know them
and love them first up is Mark Beeman
and he has a company called studio op
Mars hidden he's based out of the
Netherlands okay and this is some of his
wonderful work we're just talking about
earlier today they're on the show
sharing their knowledge doing this work
for free but that doesn't mean that they
do they do real work for free so if you
guys like the work I would highly
encourage you to look them up and give
them a shout to see if they can help you
out with your branding and identity
needs and next up is Everton and he's
based out of Brazil Brazil and he does
some really beautiful identity design
work check that out again these two guys
are looking for work so if you have
something and you have some money to
spend give them a look check them out
and I just want to mention at the top of
the show there's a couple things I want
to do because people still don't know
this about us the way we're able to
sustain what it is that we do is through
you guys purchasing our courses or kits
or just dropping a little money here and
there that's how we do and enough with a
commercial we're gonna jump right in
first up is olace Kozak I don't know how
to say that and he's from the Ukraine I
believe and this is his original mark
here I think it's the letters s OWA and
I don't know much else about this mark
so I'm gonna turn this over to Everton
Everton what are you gonna do oh you had
to turn your mic Everton
alright there we go alright alright good
see man yeah you too
I'm just trying to connect my mic it's
everything everyone is listening we are
with you we can hear you loud and clear
alright so can I do it you can do it
it's all you know nice ok so all is his
Ukranian and he sent he submitted his
logo mm-hmm oh ah oh ah I guess he's a
digital agency and he had this idea to
combine this frequently use programming
this racist
Thank You Jonah I learned this word from
him five seconds ago
so he want to combine these braces with
a big of a now because so uh means out
in Ukrainian hmm so this is logo he
submitted and I first my first thought
was this is having some problems reading
right it's difficult to to read I don't
know if it looks like a now for sure you
know it could be like a bow or a buffalo
from whatever particular reason so I
tried to to to change that and for me
one thing that I really like about logos
is one thing that it's called
attractiveness you know so when I look
at a logo I imagine if everyone would be
wearing it like prow you know showing
for people from stickers or whatever and
this I want to to to change that on his
logo so it kind of goes different ways
you know I don't know if it's a symbol
it uses only with the type or whatever
so this time I approached differently I
went straight from my sketchbook and I
try to
do some stuff that I really don't do
basically so I tried to get losing
myself a little bit from Greed's and
that stuff so I went to sketchbook and
just trying to to draw something that
really caught my attention and I went
over the internet searching for
different variations of files and I
found infinite things right yeah there's
a lot of us that have done before but I
tried to kind of incorporate that the
feeling of when I design for a company I
just want them to the people to feel the
logo that its global right not only
local but get that feeling that wow this
is a brand this is a logo really nice
and if the compare if people compared to
I don't know Apple and I hear that the
big ones that's that's for me it's just
the biggest the biggest goal so I went
from this first option here da I think
that has presence and for me have the
attractiveness
you know that I've talked about and also
not intentionally but we who have this
greater than a less than kind of thing
that it might be something that we can
use later for a brand identity oh I see
so yeah so I just went to illustrator
and started to work on the vector and
and again for me I tried to to let go
for a second about greed and stuff and
it was really challenging for me because
I never did that but at the same time
when you have the the paper and the on
the background the draw
it's it more you can mess around with
more easily so I went to the vectorizing
process I was having difficult to find
the right angle of the bars you know
there's a couple of tricks there that is
you have to to be aware
like the angled bars are usually thinner
than the the vertical ones so yeah I was
trying to pay attention of that and it
for me it was really challenging really
I but do not set this like a grid or use
a lot of mats I just went along so
hopefully that the result will be
pleasing so that's the same process
right mm-hmm
Greed's cropping lines and all of that
so when you're saying you're doing
things a little bit more optically - so
they're more balanced versus
mathematically right absolutely for for
example the white space of the day I it
didn't match at the same bars on the
angled bars you know what I mean
that's optically because when you reduce
and we will talk about this in a second
we we lost a lot of information there in
small sizes so for example if I was
doing like some work for a big studio
like let's say blind or write like a
really big studio big successful studio
like yeah yeah right yeah so I would
have to revise the logo and try to I
don't know maybe do some smaller
versions like it has below 5656 pixel
would be a different arrangement so we
have to pay attention of that so I just
went and move things around trying to
find that balance optically but not
totally but I reach a result that that I
was satisfied so I'm over long I mean
Ben it's joe minutes last night
it's very quickly he looks so angry with
those eyebrows yeah
you know what's really cool about the
way your drawing
his eyebrow which is it doubles as his
eyebrow and the beak yeah a very simple
gesture yeah yeah so no no mm-hmm
so I tried to refine as much as I can
there I don't I didn't did I didn't do
too much of details after that you know
this is the final version of the of the
logo mm-hmm Wow
I try to really create a symbol instead
of doing that the braces with two dots
below it so I tried to retry to combine
and now with the programming stuff but I
changed to greater and less is that
right correct
yeah great analyst on you yeah so and
then I went to match with some types
that I will have that lock up pretty
solid I want to be as much as cohesive
from from bars from type and symbol and
again I just did it I divided the symbol
in six equal parts but I didn't I didn't
stop a lot of time trying to measure all
things you know I just when aligning
things and finding that perfect balance
that in my opinion was good to go so and
then I tried to put it into a little
context just so we can have a more clear
idea about how can we go from it you
know different than just blacken and why
try to do this and use on the the title
that graded in in less less than to get
these kind of moods so and again just to
set here a little a little context dish
though so vibrant colors gradients maybe
illustration goes along with type goes
along with the same Bowl you know have
this
this balance here and then I can ask you
a quick question what type days are
using what's the word mark what typeface
is that so is that crow but what a crow
but I bet okay yeah yeah
all right people always want to know
Acrobat okay okay ah you're welcome and
I'm just trying to I always try to make
that the brand identities that I do it
can go really popular you know in a way
you know like just without luxury
without nothing but if you just pay
attention to the print materials bevel
emboss that kind of thing you just
elevates the brain a little further so
for me it's just had to work both ways
and I try to do again the the symbol
trying to to give that context of
program encoding and all that kind of
stuff but maintaining like this fresh
and clean image of attractiveness so to
speak I don't know if I got it but
here's the the before and after yeah
before and after yeah okay let's take a
look at this I think when I originally
looked at the original mark I wasn't
even sure what the letters were because
of the very tight tracking those getting
involved here sometimes I looked at it
so so uh and SONA
it wasn't quite sure and then the
question was probed to our audience did
you guys see the owl and some people saw
it I saw but a lot of people don't see
it and it's pretty subtle so you went in
and you did this overhaul you drew a
very geometric simplified and abstracted
version of an owl I really like what
you're drawing here because with
basically just rectangles and circles
you've constructed an owl somebody had
to ask this question about golden ratio
golden ratio yeah I'm a great freak a
little bit I can fast
no no no this one no yeah no no cool I
like it I like it a lot
so everybody
let us know in the comments below let us
know do you prefer the original so a
logo or the revised one from Emerton let
us know which one you like
A or B old or new ok i recived one they
they're saying angry one angry one the
other ones much more friendly he needs a
little eyebrow trimming a little yeah
yeah steeper yeah yeah I tried to his
move mad with the gradient the callers
you know good yeah ok any other thoughts
or questions well
hearing none let's switch it over to
Mart ok so let's take a look at my deck
so next up is a logo that was submitted
by I'm gonna butcher this and bear her
bar wrath Bart Bharath and the logo is
desert surf I like this concept I mean
as an idea because you have the waves
and you have the desert and the sand
dunes in the back with the Sun pretty
nice very simple apparel and accessories
ok so this is probably some kind of
activewear line so let's get into it
Marty ready I'm ready alright I'm ready
for you being ready so let's do this
that's my that's good going I'm gonna
share the process of my sketching it's
10 minutes so I'll just quickly go
through it and ok I can I show you the
rest yeah perfect how do we just at the
bar very high last time so I'm just
trying to I love that somebody's gonna
step up I love it first of all the name
I wasn't really sure about the name so I
actually decided to go like the whole
rebranding route this time as a service
of bits on say it's a bit of common you
know it's something that you could
easily not it would be hard to trademark
for example because it's very common
words so I in the end decided to change
the company something different okay
like a design of the logo somewhat
similar so yeah I'm just sketching using
this same simple shapes of the original
logo but in a more simple and clean way
so I'm basically using the
of the desert and waves of the sea
mm-hmm create like a really simple clean
symbol because it's it's a company that
focuses on on sports clothing and
outdoors apparel mm-hmm so I think it's
important to have something that's very
clean that you can use on like really
big sizes also really small sizes for
example if like if you have like a
jacket then you wanted to be able to be
print on the chest in really small sizes
right I want to jump in here he's using
Photoshop again so who's mine is saying
here comes the Photoshop brush god I
love that okay very cool so yeah I'm
just thinking about maybe a new name so
I've thought about making districts
serve for shorter names so my first
thought was maybe to surf because you
know it's a construction of both names
but in the end I ended up going for
something completely different for a
completely different name because a bit
later in the sketching process you will
see that almost all of my sketches have
like this end shape so almost looks like
an M so I was like hmm maybe I should
just come up with a brand name that
starts with an M so that's a bit later
in the process okay so I'm just really
going quickly through the sketches just
trying out various things and just see
what works and what doesn't work and I
really like the basic approach here so I
ended up going something that's really
really basic but it can be used in like
all kinds of sizes all kinds of
applications and the name that I end up
using think it will be shown later in
the video as well maybe it's better to
explain it then mm-hmm take me through
your thinking process here as you're
going from one form to the next what are
you thinking about so be honest I'm not
really thinking I'm just trying out
things and seeing what looks good and
what doesn't look good I'm just trying
to find a good balance between the
shapes and
it's basically just trial and error just
trying out things and throwing away what
doesn't work and keeping what doesn't
work so I think this the for me always
it's it helps not to think too much and
just try out things I think I know where
you're going with this mark I think I
know where you go and you're trying to
get the the waves and the dunes all in
one mark right yeah
yes because I want to keep it really
simple this time last time when we did
the other logo and I maybe put a bit too
much into the logo bosib it's like all
over the place for this time really
clean really simple okay I think forward
little bit people are saying they love
watching your process so this is very
satisfying to them this is by the way
I'm just going to posit here for a
second okay where it is I think I had
time to both the new name so basically
my thought process is to get a new name
was so well II can you find both units
from a desert and big waves and it's a
South Africa so I googled some surfing
South African slang and I found the word
that was Mac and it means big waves so
that was going to be my new name for a
company because I wanted to do like
basically of all rebranding because I
didn't really like the original name
does it serve because it's a bit too too
common I want to use something really
short and simple you know because it's
also both really works go with the with
the shape I'm going for okay because I
kept seeing the M so I want to create
something with the word M so here I'm
just sketching out sir some custom
typography for the brand and this goal
you said that term is Mac Mac yeah I'm
Mac and it means big wave in South
Africans like it's like surfer slang so
I thought it was pretty cool because I'm
creating big waves with the with the
symbol so I thought it was cool to have
like a brand name that matches the
typography mm-hmm are you sir for
yourself No
okay I've just have designed a couple of
kite boats for clim of mine but I've
never used them so I've three guide
boats in my room just hanging on the
wall extreme smooth muscle yeah
we've designed commercials for Audi they
did not give us any cars I'm just
letting you know yeah that sucks you got
a sec
but probably you can buy a car from what
they pay you I wish I were to yes so
yeah I'm just cleaning up the sketch and
I'm just using like really basic
geometry to get the proportions right
and just shooting it up yeah you know I
I see a thing consistently with you now
that we've spent some time together is
that when you design stuff I like how
both you guys really try to think how
does this mark live on in other ways and
being able to have common themes
elements angles really unified the
design and this is something I think a
lot of young designers struggle with
they create a mark and then they choose
a typeface
and then they design the identity system
and it feels like three separate things
in the previous example
everything was talking about using those
two brackets and then integrating them
somewhere else it's a very subtle
reference but it's kind of something
that you might subconsciously feel and
not know it's same thing with you every
single time we see you
you're like drawing from angles or
similar themes and it makes it really
cohesive so I just want to point out for
our audience so yeah I'm just going into
illustrator and I'm basically repeating
the stuff that I just in the Photoshop
just this time it's just going to be
McLean because every part of the
illustration snaps to like the grid yes
illustrator so that's why it's easier to
work no straighter after you've done a
real change sketch so more people are
wondering why Eve auto shot first
because it's easy to sketch is that the
rationale they ask this question every
single time so go ahead yeah yeah one
more time well I guess there's a lot of
people that sketch on paper first but
I'm just skipping a step of having
discussed my sketch on paper or having
to scan it so I just started Photoshop
first because it allows me to have a bit
more freedom yes different things well
you could see he works really fast and
the other thing you may not know about
Martha's he's also Nilla straighter and
that's how he sustains himself he does
illustration and logo on a dead
design so he has the hand skills so
that's why let's not make it about the
tools though yeah just it's more natural
for me I guess
any other questions mark okay so now
you're doing what you do well which is
to grid it out to make sure everything's
super clean and tight radius of circles
it's all nice and consistent right
mm-hmm yeah are using a path finder or
path builder shape builder no I'm using
something else but it's almost the same
I couldn't shoot what it's called off
this video but I'm not sure what it's
called okay I think it's almost exactly
the same it works the same I think you
have to skip one skip step or something
like that huh it's not the ship mTOR I
don't know to be honest I it's okay so
you have just recreating the topography
of this sketch as well let me ask you a
question sometimes things work out and
is sketch and then when you go to draw
it it doesn't have the same feeling
do you ever encounter that I do but I
tend to refine my sketches so much in
Photoshop already that it doesn't really
happen when I go to illustrator I see
it's already so clean and Photoshop yeah
it's already already know all the
proportions I just have to redo them and
it'll shape them like really perfect
mm-hmm so you're saying Chris no not
really cuz I'm really tight that's kind
of what he said he's like you know you
amateur designer Chris when you do a
pencil sketch when it's not good and it
happens to me all the time because when
I'm sketching with a pencil or a pen it
it feels good and then you put it into
the machine it's like oh when you
doesn't look good that's the reason why
if you find it somewhat so much in
Photoshop these days because they used
to run if you run into those problems so
that's like having it really look really
good on paper or in Photoshop and then
yeah going into the straight on just
sucks so now I'm just refining refining
refining until it looks perfect almost a
Photoshop and then I know that what I'm
going to illustrate it for look is good
as well
okay God learns over the years you know
mm-hmm so you're basically saying to me
Chris if you if you keep at it you may
learn a few things and you might develop
a process just kidding I know what you
think is done
you don't want extra step boom there you
go there's there's your tweet for today
when you think it's done go the extra
step you can quote Mart on that yeah go
one more step you guys so are you
rounding off the corners yeah
tell me why you're writing out the
corners because on the shape itself on
the icon on the left symbol the corners
also have it rounded so I just wanted to
keep it cohesive yes so what's the
secondary type you're adding there I
think it's called Oswalt's and I'm just
I'm adding it because also the original
go bad is so I'm just asking I also kept
in mind because later I will show you
some of the branding I did for this
project but I I thought the original
name was a bit limiting that's like
desert and surf but if you want to go
big with a brand then I don't think it's
smart to enter to the main so I wanted
to create something else done I want to
create something that has like more
possibilities in the long run okay so I
saw this for my deal she had like a
Beyonce project prepare it's the last
time she she did work with every session
so I just did the same and I just
created some branding aspects of the the
brand so this is the steps you can see
right the years I went from desert surf
to deserve and then to Mac as I
explained its I just thought the name
sounds better it's shorter it's more
recognizable I also create the
typography a bit bigger than it used to
be usually me to say I just this but I
made it a bit bigger because I felt that
the balance was a bit off so now I think
it looks more balanced okay so this is
just an animation of how around the
corners of the typography mm-hmm and
this is also to show that like if you
had the same space between the C and H
and the K
and you see it might not look optically
the same as between em and I so this has
a lot less space than the space between
the a and the C right and this is just
inspiration for the for the logo so it's
the mountain and the dunes the water and
waves and sky in the air and here I'm
just going into the branding of the
brand a bit mixing colors so these are
the two colors we started with and I'm
added two to be able to expand into
different areas so this one was used for
water sports this one was used for their
sand sports skateboarding and
snowboarding and I created some custom
effect or textures to use for the
branding okay and these are some of the
what we I use so this is a custom
typography and Oswald a mulatto and here
are some of textures in use so I used
especially because I thought it must
looks pretty cool because that's the
impression of like the reflection on
waves and water yeah or those books bit
like Jones it looks a bit like a
mountains of grass so I think it works
well off the brand just having that
extra set of just wasn't using a plain
color I'm using two of the colors for
each one so I'm using the blue and this
one and the orange and this one and the
red and this one so and so on and some
just basic stuff that almost every
company needs some business cards some
some paper stuff like death and some
application so for the skateboarding
part which is the red color this might
be like a tank that could be put on a
t-shirt for a surfing if you have like
the dry fit t-shirts this could be the
logo printed on the chest or whatever
and then this is for the the sand
boarding and the snowboarding maybe a
beanie or helmets or snapback some
snowboards with the same texture applied
to it and then maybe a storefront where
you can buy all this stuff and that was
it
Wow whoa nice job Thanks is this up on
your B hands page ready
is there another thing I'm going to
publish it now some people so people can
can check it out there
nice so as some of you I must admit this
trick but I think it's very smart so
it's a good trick shout out to her yeah
so if they want to look you up on B
hands what is your behance is that
Amar's or is it some is your name i use
both so studio Mars and multi-month
so I use my B months for my personal
illustrations and my client
illustrations and I used studio Mars for
the branding stuff I see so you're gonna
go to the studio up Mars and check out
this work he's gonna publish it right
after this episode airs let's go to the
comments and see you've got any
questions that we need to answer for
people and oh you know what we need to
do before I do anything we have to show
the before and after can you can we get
a side-by-side and this enough this one
where it say this before I'm just just
117 okay can we push in a little bit
tighter he's a possible to zoom okay
there that's perfect so everybody we're
seeing the evolution of desert surf and
there's a middle ground here so you can
just ignore the one in the middle and
say you started off on the left which
you saw sky sand dunes and waves and I
thought it was a very clean mark to
begin with every time people pick a
locum I wonder what they're gonna do
with that and now you see what Mark has
done here so he's taken the the dunes
and the waves and and the sky and put it
all together to make one simple and
clean mark it's very geometric and very
precise it's got some movement to it and
then he's added some custom lettering
word mark on the right and optically
spaced it out so he's done net this
style twice where he's taken the the
logo the company just yeah you know I
don't like your company name I'll change
it but you know what since this is
basically a spec project and you want to
show what you can do I encourage people
to try this in the real world we really
can't change the clients name so why not
in Fantasyland we can do it just to show
what you get you're capable of anything
that's really cool so guys let us know
on the left is original it's a and then
on the right is the black and white
version which is what Martin is done
that's version B they're starting to
vote now Oh some funny people in there
okay I'm gonna ignore you funny people
it's either A or B old or new original
original revised they're giving me other
letters besides A or B so it's just one
person I'm gonna ignore them
okay Andy I was thinking this is three
options Oh a B and C no no just forget
about the one in the middle because he
didn't he that was an exploratory phase
and in between phase he was showing you
like this is nice always to see the
evolution of something so let's take a
moment here and talk about this
sometimes when you have to present a new
logo to a client they're still attached
to their old stinky logo so showing an
interim step a middle step actually
eases the transition from the old to the
new so I do recommend you guys do this
I've seen the biggest people in logo
design do this namely Michael Beirut
Paul ran they'll show you an evolution
like how they're thinking evolves so
that you're like oh the client won't say
what did you think of that did you try
this well yes I did and that's the town
came up with this
so excellent good job okay all right so
they voted now so what do we need to do
now mark I'm a little confused well a
lot of people are voting they're split
between a n and the original yeah all
right the original and the new which is
good that's fine we're not here to tell
people that the original logo is stinky
ever
we just want to see through the lens of
a different designer how many different
ways that they can take this on and this
is what he came up with and I like it
okay anything else there were some
questions around the new ones okay
they're wondering why the C looks
smaller than the other letters
ooh all right that's a good question
Mart how do you want to respond to that
well it does but I don't think it's
possible to create a C in the same style
as the M&E hey I didn't really it didn't
really bother me because the the
original symbol honestly what I created
also has this round shape right here so
that's why I decided to use this one but
I can see what it coming from it makes
sense but I think it still looks
optically Brown yes it's it's well
spaced I think it's an issue of real
estate screen real estate that it's not
as horizontal as the other ones so that
that's what they're reacting to okay
yeah very good okay mark what do we need
to do do we need to do anything else as
far as this logo I think everybody
there's split between it but we're good
okay questions all right so here's what
I'm going to say to you guys because
you're thinking too
right now after watching this episode
how do I get my work reviewed well it's
kind of a little subjective and totally
random but there's one way for sure that
you won't be included in this is if
you're feeling a case of FOMO
FOMO you need to go and follow the
futures page on Facebook the future I
think it's the futures here and then
there's a post here and says you know
submit your logo designs here and
essentially all the local therapists the
groups of three that we have they comb
through and they pick a look at it
speaks to them sometimes they love it
they think they can improve on it
sometimes they hate it and they'll reach
out to you so make sure you're reachable
and then send them the vector artwork
and then they will take a spin at it at
kind of revising it and seeing what
happens there okay yeah you can stop
sure okay so a couple other things I
need to talk about some business I don't
know if you guys notice I'm wearing a
brand new snapback cap it literally
arrived today and I just want to say
thank you to would brim hats 24k but
would brim hats you'll notice that
there's this new fancy TFA monogram the
future Academy that's laser engraved and
glued on his hat it's looking really
spiffy you guys so I just want to shout
out thank you very much for sending me
the Hat wood brim hats guys go check
them out and the last a little bit I
have to tell you guys about is we are
doing not just one livestream today we
are doing two live streams today too
we're gonna be switching channels we're
going back to the futures main channel
not the Academy and we're gonna be
talking about design from scratch you've
watched episode a little bit of drama
some interesting things going on the
gang that are gonna get together I want
to talk about the show after the show
that's what we're gonna do so I think
that's it now on behalf of everybody
that is tuning in myself mark and Jonah
we want to say thank you to our two most
consistent prolific logo therapists
remember guys if you like their work
look them up on the web how do they get
in touch with you Mart what do they go
where do they go
tell us your your.com address
might be Muslim Coleman studio Mars coma
okay Mar Beeman's calm and studio barse
calm and Everton how do they get a hold
of you where do they go Sarah Claire
Johnny cambiar okay try smell that you
guys
it's gonna be a good one just look up
this episode screen capture and then you
can look them up they're both available
for the right kinds of projects and
they're do a lot of branding of any
design so look them up show them selves
send them some money just or just say hi
or thank you and follow them on social
media that's it you guys thank you very
much I'm gonna remind everybody right
now Jonah I'm gonna remind everybody to
not just good to like comment and
subscribe to this channel and turn off
notifications we'll see you guys next
time
peace everybody we're out of here
where's my music there it is that's it
for us to care about it see you